trump let's talk about trump let's talk
about trump here donald trump
set to visit border before kamala here's
newsweek story
donald trump has increased pressure on
vice president kamala harris as he
announces he will visit the u.s mexico
border before late june trump who made
building
a wall to combat immigration one of his
key presidential campaign promises said
he would visit our nations down
decimated a southern border with texas
governor greg gavin on june 30th biden
is also for
facing criticism for the record levels
of my immigrant migrants
attempting to enter the country
illegally since his time in office after
walking back some of trump's more
hardline immigration policies in an
attempt to provide a more humane
approach in april nearly 179 000 people
were detained
trying to enter the border the highest
level since april of last year abbott
sent a letter to biden
in late march demanding answers to the
humanitarian crisis at the border abbott
said he plans to build his own wall
along the state's border with mexico
although it is
unclear if he has the resources funds or
authority
to do so adam i'm going to go to you
first what do you think about the story
here i i got to tell you this
the the everything with the board are so
politicized and i don't have the answers
here i don't think anyone does that's
the biggest problem here
i will say that you know i i'm a big fan
of pop culture did you see the
trending video that was going on with
kamala harris and donald trump this
weekend no
all right well if you've got kids in the
room use your earmuffs
it was really actually hilarious so i've
never been to europe either yeah
the um kamala harris came out
this was the video kamala harris being
said basically saying
if you're in mexico don't come
do not yeah don't come and then it cuts
it donald trump goes
i'm going to come
it actually doesn't go like that it
doesn't say mexico you're right
she just said she just says don't come
exactly don't come
exactly he says oh i'm gonna come it's
just
not to come he's coming anyway that's a
that's a brash man right there all right
all right all right
you're not allowed to have fun on biz
doc time it's time to get down to your
spot to cancel y'all
do not cancel me biz doc go ahead listen
catman
this is all about the narrative right
what was the narrative
they wanted to get him out of office
they wanted him defeated
the re-election so the whole narrative
on
immigration was you're putting kids in
cages you're not letting people come
here they just want freedom here
and keep the borders open so whatever
trump was trying to do they were trying
to do the opposite and they were
spinning it for the purpose of
voting blocks okay that's what that was
the narrative
now it goes the other way the other way
is now
biden's in office trump is gone and
you've got arizona
and texas and the city of austin and
remember
there's a lot of californians are in
austin there's a big thing down there
and all these billboards and t-shirts
you can get keep austin weird
mean weirder than the rest of texas
meaning more lavender than blue or red
the narrative is now hey we have some
really real problems here need to be
cleaned up
we got problems here san francisco does
not like national news stories talking
about
feces urine syringes and homelessness
they don't like it
and there are people there that want to
see it fixed
and now it's a different side of the
narrative the narrative when you're
getting trump out is
is the whole problem at the border is
about trump and give these people
freedom now the vice president is going
down there saying
do not come here don't stop i'm gonna do
the whole thing she's saying
don't come across this is a bigger
problem we won't know why they're
leaving their country
what did trump say stop
the point they're flipping the narrative
and
it is so cruel to the american voter it
is so cruel to
the people that you're supposed to be
serving that are living in these
communities where these secondary
problems are happening
because there's no word for these folks
to go if they were joining up with
relatives they were finding a job they
had things going
then give us your tired reporter huddled
masses yearning to briefly come across
so what's your solution be
solution-oriented you're identifying the
problem
is that there are america is not a race
america
is a melting pot and experiment of
people that came from somewhere
and have a door at the border welcome
people that are refugees but there's a
process to do it you can't have them
streaming across
a beautiful door and one one moment
you've got people just all over the
border issue and just
ignoring all the secondary issues
because you just want to get trump out
of office
and now they're willing to look at some
of these these problems
and it's like they're going the other
way it's the hypocrisy of this
is just stifling let me ask you you ever
lived in a gated community
well would a high-rise be considered a
gated community where you lived with
millionaires and deca millionaires where
you lived there was a lot of rich people
in that building that's true
that's that that's called the gated
community yeah right there was a lot of
security when people came here
how'd you like that it's nice it's nice
right okay
i do as well i think america's got to
become a gated community
because where do people typically want
to go to
the fanciest places what's the fanciest
country in the world
still today it's monaco where you lived
is a pretty fancy place it's a beautiful
place right
it was gated i think it's nothing
nothing wrong with
america being gated as well to protect
itself especially people who are living
down there here's the other part i'll
tell you about this
um do you think two years ago go ahead
no do you think we need a gate on both
sides
uh not on canada's side okay you know
why you know why because canadian
government is actually doing a decent
job keeping their people there
and canadian are not trying to break the
law to come down here we don't have a
canadian border problem
we have a south and central america
problem it's not just mexico salvadorans
are going through guatemala
to make it it's a south and central
america problem not a canada problem
that we have
a border prime i mean nobody from europe
is swimming out here it's a long swim so
it's going to be we don't need to put a
border between there because the sharks
are going to handle that
themselves we don't need to worry about
that we got great security in the
atlantic ocean canadians are some of the
greatest people in the world
they are except for any one of them in
this room they got some issues everybody
else i would say yes now let's talk
about this nice
canadians are very good and they know
how to drink a lot of beer by the way
kokanee so here's a
here's a part about this here so for me
it's very simple
when we started our youtube channel and
then we changed the channel to
valuetainment
and we started doing a couple interviews
and i started liking doing interviews
because i enjoy
people's stories i like talking to
people a lot of the people that were
doing interviews at the time
they would only interview people that
came to their show it's like no you
don't come to me i'm not doing the
interview
i told my guys here's what we're gonna
be doing we will go to them
okay and here's what i want you to do
when i go to cities to do an interview i
want you to set me up with three if
there's three interviews in a city i'll
go so my booker had one job they're
gonna put three interviews in a city
i'm going so i'd go to new york time
remember is my schedule let me tell you
it's not easy
because you have to remember the notes
the facts all that stuff and the
questions so you're sitting down one
minute from
you know a general who was a general
that we interviewed in new york
uh mcchrystal and then i'm sitting with
this uh scaramucci then i'm sitting with
bernard carrick then i'm sitting with it
it was back
it was ariana huffington then i'm
sitting with you back to back to back to
back to back then you got to get ready
for the questions you're asking right
okay
but we went to the guests because we
were a small youtube channel we only had
50
000 subs 80 000 subs 100 000 subs so we
went to them
what happened eventually eventually we
got a half a million subs
a million subs couple million subs three
million subs now people are willing to
come over here why
because we now earn the right but even
today yesterday
i flew out to do an interview with one
of the most powerful attorneys in the
world that many know about i'll
you know very soon i'll talk about who i
was with yesterday a two-hour interview
ended up being six hours at his place
that we were with
and talking about stories and seeing
stuff that
it's just private stuff that we talked
about which will
you know we'll share with the world here
soon who the person was that i
interviewed
moral the story is this anybody that i
ever met
who kept crushing it they always went to
the problem
they always went to the source they
always went to the customer
goldman sachs they're having a
conversation with the other investment
bankers
you know what the biggest complaint was
here's what the biggest complaint was
why some investment bankers were losing
business to goldman sachs i can't
believe i'm playing with a mango right
now
he says the reason why we're losing
business to goldman sachs is because
goldman sachs investment bankers still
get on the plane and go meet with the
client to be
their money backers they still are
willing to go meet with them
while everybody else is just doing zoom
zoom zoom zoom zoom
goldman said we're going to come and
meet with you guess what happened during
covet
they got the big money the other guys
are like don't leave your office sit
right there god forbid something were to
happen
goldman got the business very simple
that's why they weren't careful
they weren't careless they were careful
is what they do okay my sales guys i
have a guy in the company
uh uh sheena mats apollo you've met them
before we paid them nearly 300 last
month okay is what they made okay
a month you know in a month you know
what you know what they're very good at
i i have
many guys that were bigger than them
when we were coming up and i would tell
them
go meet the clients and they would say
no why would i go they need to come to
me i don't drive two hours i don't drive
three hours
what does sheena matsupala do they'll
fly to memphis
they'll fly to seattle they'll fly to
new york they'll fly to
baltimore they'll fly to orlando they'll
fly to san diego they'll fly to arizona
they go to people they didn't make the
money last month by luck
they made it because they went to the
source to the customer they went there
right okay
um trump is doing
what they should be doing he's going
where the problem is and by the way
here's what's a very bad look for them
right now
everybody in america lester holt is
asking kamala harris why are you not
going to the border
the former president whom you kicked out
whom you silenced on all of social media
platforms said
don't worry i'm going to go over there
and i'm going to go with greg greg
abbott and we're going to go see what's
going on
and try to help and influence and give
support to the people that are working
on the border because you're not gonna
ever know what they do at the border
until you go see what they're gonna do
at the border
there's a big difference between you
seeing it on a video there's a big
difference between you reading an
article about it
there's a big difference between me
sending you to go to the border versus i
go to the border there's a very very big
difference for you to see it
you gain loyalty that way years ago one
of the best leadership books i ever read
was by donald t phillips called lincoln
on leadership
you know what lincoln on leadership said
he said circulate
amongst your troops it's what made
lincoln
so admired by the people that work with
them he went and circulated amongst his
troops he would say how you doing
private
how you doing specialist how you doing
corporal
how are things everything good how we
looking
circulate amongst your troops if you
ever seen a movie lincoln played by
daniel day lewis you'll see where he's
sitting he's sitting
amongst the troops it's why they call
him the greatest
president of all time because he went
and circulated amongst the troops he
didn't sit back and order others what to
do
he went and circulated amongst the
troops
and that's all 45 is doing right now
something 46
can learn something from and take some
notes and say you know what
maybe we ought to go out there because
we're looking at fools right now that
the former president needs to go out and
we're not even going there and the
number one issue
one of the biggest issues we're facing
right now in america is what immigration
because we made people in south and
central america think
it's open borders come on down it's not
a good look for the current
administration and all i can tell you is
trump capitalized on an opportunity and
it looks very good for him for 2024
not saying he's going to run or not it's
a very good look for him because it
shows
republicans care more about the border
than democrats do
historically democrats have always been
known what they care more about
those coming across the border more than
anybody else's does but they're not
going there
if republicans win that statement which
is what
republicans care more about the border
than others is that a small percentage
could that be a half a point could that
be one point could that be a quarter of
a point could that be a point and a half
it could be does the point and a half
mean anything in midterms
does a point mean anything in midterms i
mean trump just announced he's going on
a
tour across the country with what bill
o'reilly to go and do what to talk and
you know address issues and answer
questions and he's going out there
working as a
president that's just not sitting there
saying i'ma go out there and circulate
amongst the troops
look anybody whether it's your
competitors
anybody in politics and business and
sports anybody that does that you better
tip your hat off to them and say listen
i got respect for this guys because he
wants to play ball
and that percent and a half by the way
takes a lot of work and energy to do
that
a lot of work and energy to do that
that's why many don't want to do it it's
funny you just said percent and a half
and
just remember a percent and a half is a
three-point swing right
the net difference is three that's the
whole ball game
on the last four presidential elections
that's the ball game so
you you you move the populist something
like that yep
on on a lightning rod issue like this
it's
it it's defining and then the
other guy is now making the policies
it's so funny people look at
you're so right about things you're
saying today you know people
if let me put it this way if you're
watching a weatherman by the way this is
not a left or right thing george bush
senior has become so much above
like i'm above everybody else i'm the
former director of cia i have more
experience in politics than anybody else
and the lady from our the lady asked her
ask him the question about debt
how does the national debt affect your
family he says what you don't think i'm
affected by the debt
and then bill clinton comes and says
ma'am can you please tell me how it's
affecting your life
and a lady answered questions you know
what in the state of arkansas here's
what i do
what we've done in our state is we
understand what it is to go through this
and i understand your feelings and if
you vote me as your president i will be
able to
data it's the economy stupid bill
clinton equals donald trump
in this situation circulating amongst
troops absolutely
they relate to the average person why do
you think um comma some
this has to be a strategy of some some
like i'm not a big fan of negative
attention
yeah why don't you get attention if she
doesn't go if she goes
so that's the reason that they're saying
look kamala don't go
because if you do go it's going to be a
lot of negative attention is at the
border
the border is a mess it's like bad pr
they do so they're making a conscious
decision i'm going to step back because
her response was i've never been to
europe which was i think was ridiculous
but okay there must be a reason she's
not let's just say you got your you
always hide your brother away from your
girl
for whatever reason okay and then you go
and you
your girl meets your brother and all she
talks about on the drive back from
dinner is your brother
and you're like dude you're with me why
are you talking about my brother she's
actually kind of and she says
you know what i like your brother he's
so funny i like him so much
that story he said oh my gosh and you're
just like
ah i can't believe he's talking about
this i don't want to bring attention to
it right this is
the level of insecurity everybody has to
level them in security this
is purely an insecurity thing if they go
to the border
it's going to show that trump's policies
did better on the border than theirs
that is not going to help them for the
next two years so you cannot bring
attention in an area where trump won so
that is a strategic move
brilliant it is a strategic move but
it's not a brilliant strategic move
it backfires it gives an opening to
trump what they had to do is the
following this would have been a better
move on them my suggestion
could be wrong i'm just an entrepreneur
they could have gone there
together and they could have said here's
what's happening
here's the issue here's what we have to
do about it we're working on it right
now we have our team over there and i
went for myself to see it
this is what we're doing right this is
what we're not doing right this is what
we're going to get to the bottom of give
us 90 days
that's the better approach and the
american people you know what they would
have said okay cool
all right let's move on you know the
whole thing about the the the i'm sorry
where you go out there and you say sorry
and then people move on like
okay cool that's that's cool i
appreciate no problem and just kind of
move on
people forget sometimes people just want
to know they're putting paying the
putting the right attention to the issue
that matters to them they're not doing
it with this you know what would have
been a boss move
what if you do a bipartisan group that
goes down together not going to happen
that's my point is that there's so both
sides
presidents are the most divisive
presidents both sides in a long time
like at the end of the day do you want
to fix the issues or do you want to play
politics if you actually want to fix the
issue
you bring a kamala who goes with greg
abbott you bring a beta o'rourke and you
bring
uh representatives from arizona texas
from both sides and you actually figure
it out but no they want to play politics
both sides are guilty both obama and
trump did this
they both did it where was getting away
from the center
that we win when we go more to the
center i love i love what bill
bill maher is doing right now i love
what stewart is doing right now
i love what russell brand is doing right
now i love what tucker's doing right now
i love what a lot of these guys are
doing right now where they're calling
out both sides you need more of that a
little bit of hannity is
hannity trump can't do nothing wrong in
hannity's eyes but trump can do a lot
wrong
in tucker's eyes you need some of that
today and it's bringing us more to the
center
more unifying less dividing so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye